hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skincare nerd and
a bit of a mess i don't know about you but over
the last year with lockdowns and working from
home and general stress my daily routine has
just gone out the window i keep losing track
of when i last changed my sheets when i should
be eating lunch when i should go to sleep
some days i've even forgotten to shower
until it's too late for me to shower
so a lot of nights i just haven't had the energy
to do a proper full skincare routine it's sort of
like the last thing on my mind and with mask
wearing my skin has needed more attention
i'm getting a lot of congestion around my chin
and i might be starting to develop a little bit
of perioral dermatitis so today i thought i'd
talk about some skin care products that i found
really helpful when i've just been too lazy
to do a proper routine or when i have to play
catch-up with my skincare let me know what
products you like using for this if you
use the same products as me if you like
talking about the science behind beauty
products click the like the subscribe and the
nerdification bell so you don't miss any videos
i'm going to start with today's video
sponsor and it's a product that i think
a lot of you knew i was going to talk about
for this which is bioderma's micellar water
i talk about this a lot but analyzing an
ingredients list is useful to an extent
but because products are so complex you can't
tell everything just from the ingredients list
that's why testing products on actual people
getting clinical evidence is so valuable in
getting science-based skin care and that's why so
many skin care experts scientists dermatologists
estheticians recommend bioderma all the time
they are so thorough with their clinical testing
they collaborate with research institutes
and dermatologists to create their products
and that means they end up with products that
just work really well for a lot of people i've
raved about their micellar water before and it's
become such a staple for me over the last year
this is actually the world's first micellar
water it's the product that started the craze
it's a really gentle cleanser that's effective
at removing dirt oil makeup and pollution without
disrupting the skin's barrier very much and so
that makes it really good for sensitive skin
in clinical testing 97% of people with fragile
or sensitive skin found they had a soothing
effect from this cleanser i've talked to so many
dermatologists and makeup artists and people with
sensitive skin who also rave about this now not
all micellar waters are formulated for sensitive
skin but this one has a number of features that
makes it really good it has a skin friendly pH
of 5.5 and it's fragrance free and it contains
one single gentle surfactant now i know we tend
to think of surfactants as harsh irritating
ingredients but it's actually a really broad
category unlike a lot of rinse-off cleanses and
other micellar waters on the market this only has
one super gentle non-ionic surfactant ingredient
it's a skin softening emollient moisturizer that
can actually counteract irritation the water they
use is also special it's highly purified injection
quality water and in a lot of other cosmetic
products the water has endotoxins which for most
people is okay but if you have very sensitive skin
it can be irritating i love this cleanser you can
use it as the first step of a double cleansing
routine or i usually use it as a standalone
cleanser i use it with reusable cotton pads mine
are from bambu face and i found that these are
really gentle i used to use it with cheap cotton
pads and i found that my skin was getting a bit
sensitive and that was actually because the cotton
pad was rough once i switched to a softer pad i
found that i didn't have issues so it was just
the physical exfoliation from the cotton pad
so if i have makeup on i'll probably use two
cotton pads if i don't have makeup i'll just use
one and then wipe it all over my face then chuck
this into the laundry it also used to be my travel
cleanser back when we were actually traveling i've
also started using this in the morning just as a
morning cleanse if you know my skincare routine
i used to just splash my face with water and then
pat it off because my skin's really dehydration
prone but my skin's changed so much from wearing
masks after seeing a dermal clinician which
is what we call estheticians in australia she
suggested that maybe i should cleanse my face in
the morning as well maybe that one cleanse in the
evening wasn't quite enough so i've just started
doing this i'll keep you updated on how that goes
so apart from the micellar water which i think
is my one big love from bioderma they have lots
of other great products i feel like everyone in my
family is now using at least one bioderma product
another of my favorites is the sebium foaming
gel cleanser which is what i use a lot of the
time when i do a proper cleanse i've reviewed the
sebium range before it contains a bunch of actives
that really help with pimples without drying
out your skin so it helps with poor clogging
and oil and the whole range works really
well alongside traditional acne treatments
i also love the autoderm range especially in
winter it's great for dry skin it's really
good for strengthening your
barrier and restoring lipids
the next product i'm talking about is kate
somerville's exfolikate this is a rinse off
exfoliating product i guess you could call it a
peel or a mask you're meant to leave it on for
about two minutes and this is my catch-up product
for when i've forgotten to exfoliate i use this
a lot in the shower and because it's rinse off it
fits in really easily with the rest of my routine
i don't have to worry about whether or not it's
going to interact with something else or pill up
this is a chemical and physical and enzyme
exfoliant so it's got alpha hydroxy acid it's
got lactic acid bha which is salicylic acid it has
tiny silica scrubbing granules so you apply it by
massaging it on for about 30 seconds and then
you'd leave it on after that for you're meant
to leave it on for a total of two minutes i'm
sure i've left it on for longer without problems
there's also three types of enzymes in this it's
got papaya pumpkin and pineapple enzymes so it's
basically ticked off every exfoliation category
i regularly use apart from maybe peeling gel and
phas now this is a bit expensive it's a bit more
bougie than i normally go for but it lasts for
ages so i only use about a pencil eraser's worth
every time and i think in total i think i'm on my
second tube they also recently launched a 15 mL
version which is a bit more affordable so it's
great if you're not sure if you want to commit
to a proper tube yet i've tried some other peel
products but i always end up going back to
this because it works really well it has all
three types of exfoliants but it also just has a
really great texture it's a thick green paste and
it stays on your skin really well it doesn't drip
down your face when you're in the shower with all
the steam a lot of other peel products are very
liquid and very runny so when i'm in the shower
i can feel it dripping down my face this one does
not so i am still paranoid enough to keep it above
my eyebrows but yeah i haven't really felt this
running into my eyes yet and i still have my eyes
next i have the paula's choice 0.3% retinol
and 2% bakuchiol treatment i really like this
because it has this combination bakuchiol
is a plant extract that helps with wrinkles
and hyperpigmentation and it's been marketed as
like an alternative to retinol it really isn't
it's not a retinoid it doesn't work the same way
even though it has a similar overall effect but
so do a lot of other ingredients in skin care
but it is still a pretty promising ingredient
now according to paula's choice the bakuchiol
can help the retinol work more effectively
i don't know what evidence they have for this i
tried looking through their references but they
have a really awful referencing system so i
can't tell what paper they're talking about
anyway this is a really nice light lotion apart
from the retinol and bakuchiol there's also
peptides and skin soothing ingredients and so
that means we have a retinol product that isn't
all that irritating which means you don't have to
be that careful with the application some nights
i'm just too tired to carefully measure out a tiny
bit of tretinoin i can't trust myself with that
responsibility because it's got that combination
of ingredients i don't feel like i need to use
extra products and because my skin is more on the
oily side this works as my moisturizer as well
if your skin is a bit drier then maybe that
won't work you might need an extra product
along the same lines this is kate ryan's total
nutrition night repair complex i've raved about
this product before it's a very similar idea it's
an all-in-one product that just makes your skin
look really nice the next day it has a bit of
everything it's got niacinamide retinyl acetate
centella extract and antioxidants so this is
really great for when i want my skin to look a bit
nicer but i also don't want to risk any sort of
irritation so the night before filming a video
now on nights when i feel a bit more capable of
using tret i really love the klair's midnight
blue calming cream this is really good
for mixing with tretinoin and it calms
the skin down a bit so if i go a little bit
overboard on the tret then i'm a bit safer
and it also helps the tretinoin spread over
skin much faster so i just mix it on the palm
of my hand with about a half pea-sized amount
of tretinoin on and then spread it all over
i've also been enjoying glow recipe's lip
pop so they're a skin care brand that have
recently branched out and they've
launched lip products and body products
they have a lot of fruit branding so this
smells delicious it smells like watermelon
it's a really rich soft moisturizing lip balm and
it also doubles up as a lip scrub it's got little
sugar granules in it that dissolve over time and
alpha hydroxy acids and so i use this at night
it also has a little bit of a stain in it
i have the sort of coloring where i look
a little bit dead if i don't have some sort
of color on my face especially on the lips
and so wearing this at night means that when i
wake up in the morning my lips are already sort of
a little bit made up and so if i just wake up five
minutes before a zoom call i don't look too bad
i hope you like the video if you have any other
product suggestions for me to incorporate into my
lazy skincare toolkit let me know you
can give it a thumbs up and subscribe
for more videos like this you can also
follow me on instagram and check out my
blog for more of the science behind beauty
products see you next time to nerd out more